hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason and
I'm joined by Zach weismiller of Reason
TV Zach please say hello hello and we
are talking yet again in a recent live
stream with Robbie Suave who is dialing
in from Washington D.C we are here in
particular to talk about two uh just
kind of bombshell stories that Robbie
has put out uh one is going to be the
next cover story of the magazine and
then there's a live story up today with
emails but this is uh Robbie has uh
gotten his hands on a series of emails
between Facebook people and the CDC and
a couple of other government actors to
show exactly how the CDC and Facebook
were coordinating attempts to uh keep
disinformation misinformation Mal
information uh from getting onto that
platform during the height of the covid
hysteria Robbie why don't you uh start
off by telling us exactly exactly you
know what's what's the import of the uh
of the stories that we're talking about
here today
sure so these are emails for the most
part from the CDC to Facebook metas the
parent company of Facebook it owns
Facebook and Instagram uh about pandemic
coveted related content vaccine related
content that appeared
um during the years of the pandemic I
think my report is in keeping I hope at
least with what was done in the Twitter
files you know these series of reports
that have taken place with journalist
Matt taibi and Barry Weiss and some
other people that shed light on how much
communication there was between
government actors and Twitter on a bunch
of issues election covet Hunter Biden
Etc what I'm saying is the same exact
thing was happening with Facebook and
then presumably other platforms as well
the amount of conversations that
government employees and the social
media companies that decide how much you
can speak about certain subjects it's a
lot it's a lot more than I would have
guessed several years ago and I think
that fact in another itself is
interesting I think the public has a
right to know about how much
conversations there were about what you
were allowed to say between the CDC and
Facebook okay and uh just a couple of
quick things to get out of the way one I
want to point out reason uh magazine is
published The Reason Foundation of 501c3
non-profit we have received donations
from meta the parent company of Facebook
so uh you know that's out there
um but true to form we are reporting our
story as we see them as we find them uh
Robbie can you tell me where did you get
the emails
yeah so these are emails that uh
probably anyone could get if they
depending on how they ask this is part
of a lawsuit between uh the state of
Missouri has filed this lawsuit against
the Biden Administration for the
policies that led to covid skeptical
people uh being kicked off Twitter and
some other places right uh the new civil
liberties Alliance is a non-profit civil
liberties group that is participating in
the lawsuit and I I got them as a result
of that other reporters other interested
parties may have gotten them as well I
think I'm the first person to kind of
package them in this way or release them
as I did and explain why I think they're
so interesting
um so that's you know that's what's
going on there great uh one more quick
point that I'm going to throw out to uh
Zach to ask a question but uh one for
people out there listening uh you know
you may not be on Facebook that much
anymore I know I am not I use Facebook
as kind of like uh you know I go there
to post things for my adoring fans and
things like that but I I you know
there's a sense particularly in the
media class that Facebook is you know
it's your grandfather's Oldsmobile
nobody [ __ ] cares about it Facebook
if any of these platforms is the Public
Square Facebook certainly globally but
even in North America it is I don't know
like probably a factor of 10 bigger than
uh Twitter in terms of average daily
users it is a place where people share
live swap a lot of information uh the
other thing I want to say is also you
know uh at the end of the year we had a
reason webathon one of the gifts if you
gave a certain amount of money was a
recent stress ball mine showed up
yesterday and uh you know it's a couple
weeks late because I could have been
squeezing this thing for all of 2022 and
probably the rest of this year Zach uh
what do you want to ask Robbie well yeah
and I'll just throw in there that
I've been off Facebook since about 2016.
so I'm one of those people who you know
in my personal life I kind of like
downplay the importance of it but you're
you're right it is kind of the big the
big boy in the room
um although it's been losing it's been
steadily losing uh users especially in
the US over recent years and
um I think that there's a lot of uh
compete you know they're facing a lot of
competitive pressure which which is a
good thing and something we can probably
get into a little bit more later but uh
I wanted to start off asking Robbie
about this sentence that I highlighted
from his web article
um which where you can go to see uh some
of these embedded emails that we're
going to be discussing today
um and you say Robbie that Facebook
moderators were in constant contact with
the CDC and routinely asked government
Health officials to vet claims relating
to the virus mitigation efforts such as
masks and vaccines
um so I as a pertains to the emails here
I just want to know you know before we
get into the big picture of all this
this issue raises which which you delve
into in in the cover story that we
displayed earlier tell us specifically
about some of the emails
um who's involved in them what are some
of the most what are some of the most
interesting and revealing ones say
between the cdc's kind of communications
officer that office and moderators at
meta and they're very friendly they're
very collegial in fact uh meta describes
the CDC as their colleagues in including
in emails where they've cc'd a bunch of
uh kind of comms people who are just in
a in the private sector and working to
help various government Health agencies
get their message across but um they ask
they send specific claims they'll say uh
in these emails several times many times
meta will say we're seeing this claim
going really viral on Facebook how do
you feel about this claim uh you know is
it is it true could it be true and then
they'll they'll ask questions eventually
they start asking well is this harmful
how harmful this is is this and then
much later it becomes do you think this
could cause vaccine hesitancy and the
cdc's saying well anything could cause
vaccine hesitancy so yes uh it's it's a
it's a very deferential friendly and
deferential series of messages they are
essentially
um putting out giving the CDC sort of de
facto control over what you were allowed
to say on these controversial subjects
they were they were
totally giving it to the CDC in terms of
who was going to be the decision maker
on whether this was a legitimate topic
of discussion
um yeah let's go through uh another
specific email
um Zach and uh so we'll talk about it in
that context sure I mean here here's one
um about what Robbie was talking about
where the Facebook is kind of emailing
the CDC and saying look here's some of
the things that are trending could you
just weigh in on this give us your
opinion of what you think of these
Trends uh and this email at the top is
uh their CDC contact Carol Crawford
saying thank you very helpful the one I
have highlighted here has to do with
double masking and says that uh some
high interaction posts from Pages mocked
the idea of double masking and fauci's
changing position on it while in groups
criticism came in meme form uh it's it's
unclear if any action was taken on that
but it's kind of interesting that that
was something that would be you know
flagged for a government agency to
review
um another example that maybe is a
little more substantive here is
um this is just a list of claims that
were being made after the vaccine came
out a lot of these are you know clearly
crazy and untrue
um coveted vaccines cause Alzheimer's
coveted vaccines causing magnetism
um so and then you know if you keep
going uh well we'll get to the the lab
leak in a second but let's start with
those two because on one hand you have
you know some criticism of fauci which
it seems like just kind of some some
good-natured meming and then on the
other hand you've got these uh rather
insane and possibly harmful claims being
made
what is uh the approach that uh you know
what is wrong with the approach that
Facebook is taking to yeah look to be
clear
claims are going viral on Facebook that
yeah that I think are crazy I mean I'm
not an anti-vaccine person I'm
vaccinated right um yeah I think it
should be your choice but I generally in
favor of it but look I kind of just
thought it was interesting that
Facebook's
um operating procedure here was to leave
it up to the CDC to decide that every
time something makes them uncomfortable
they send an email and they say well
what do you guys think about this
especially given you know what was going
on in public all that time you have
political figures Democratic political
figures including Joe Biden at one point
in July of 2021 as some of these emails
are being sent Joe Biden says Facebook
is killing people he that's his that's a
quote and his communications director
says on TV I believe Tamika Brzezinski
says you know if they don't do more to
clamp down up this misinformation is
killing people if they don't do more
their regulation should be tweaked to
cause them more pain they should change
section 230. so they're being threatened
in public by Democratic political
figures and then behind the scenes
they're basically putting the CDC in
charge of all the policies they can and
I wonder if there's some connection
there and if that should be concerning
to civil Libertarians and everyone else
maybe the answer is no but I I wanted
people to know I I thought people would
be a little taken aback by how much
discussion went on between Facebook and
the CDC
it just so happens I pulled those two
clips that you referenced and I'd like
to play them so everyone can see and
remember the context of what what kind
of messages were going out from the top
as all this was happening all this you
know internal communication was
happening uh because I think that's
going to relate to uh you know the the
legal challenge that uh you know you you
pulled these emails uh from so first
here's the Biden clip uh where he uh
said that social media companies are
killing people by not being more
aggressive uh removing accusing social
media companies of killing people for
allowing vaccine myths to circulate
online they're killing people
I mean it really they'll look the only
pandemics we have is among the
unvaccinated
and then here's his communication
director this is all happening around
the same period of time the president
said he was open to getting rid of
section 230 and I'm just wondering if
he's
open to amending 230 when Facebook and
Twitter and other social media Outlets
spread false information
that cause Americans harm shouldn't they
be held accountable in a real way
shouldn't they be liable for publishing
that information and then open to
lawsuits
well we're reviewing that and certainly
they should be held accountable and I
think you've heard the president speak
very aggressively about this he
understands this is an important piece
of
so this is like the the troubling
pattern that we discussed in a previous
stream and that it's difficult to you
know there's a lot of blurry lines here
because the you know the you know
government
people who work in the federal
government are careful enough not to say
you know take this down or else but
there is this kind of concerted pressure
campaign yeah that that's for Adam
Schiff and members of Congress to do it
right right yeah they'll put that out on
their uh Twitter feed but you know even
that they will say well I'm just uh you
know expressing my my opinion it's not
an actual threat so there's you know
tiptoeing up to the line and you know
how how do we know
when that's been you know very clearly
crossed
right and I I think what you're seeing
is that you've created an environment
where because I so I don't want to blame
meta too much of course they feel like
given those public threats that better
safe than sorry let's just do whatever
the government tells us to do that's our
safest from a from a Regulatory
Compliance standpoint honestly that's
what we saw with Twitter the more of the
Twitter Files come out uh the more
um I actually feel a little bit for Joel
Roth who was the kind of head moderator
who was portrayed very negatively in the
initial dispatches but the more of it we
see what you see is in terms of election
misinformation stuff you see you know
the FBI come to them over and over again
saying you're you're flooded with
russian-based disinformation you know
elections are vulnerable unless you do
something they turn around and say uh we
looked at those accounts we're not
seeing that we think this is fine and
then it's oh it's Relentless and it's
more threatening and it's like and and
then it's the FBI saying you know
there's Democratic politicians very
interested in this the media is very
interested in this you're really not
going to do anything you're really not
going to do anything you see their
resolve waiver you see and then finally
they're like okay whatever it will tell
us what are the accounts you want us to
take down that's what was going on now
we look at Facebook of course they're
asking the CDC for everything for every
and you know go to going to this one lab
leak can I uh you know before we get to
the lab like I also asked just to you
know kind of put this out there
um you know a lot of what they're asking
is basically like you know there's a
bunch of people online who are saying
that I got the vaccine and now Forks
stick to my cheeks and things like that
is there any truth to that is there you
know they run through a list of popular
common things that doesn't strike me
necessarily as like oh you know we're
quaking on our boots or tell us what to
do that does actually seem to be kind of
you know I want to say corporate uh you
know responsible corporate behavior in
the best way possible unironically like
they're trying to get information from
the agency that is supposed to know this
stuff right and unlike election
misinformation and whatnot this you know
particularly during the pandemic there
should be right or wrong answers for
most of this stuff right
well so I mean yeah so there's that and
then the other question is that so
they're talking to them and you know we
also have at the same time we have like
you know the heads of these corporations
and the heads ahead of the US government
you know attacking them
um it's not clear to me necessarily that
everybody is that people are working in
concert but how do we know that Facebook
said okay you you gave us this
information and now we quash certain
accounts or we minimize the reach Etc do
we know how that worked because part of
what the Twitter file showed us was you
know there were actual blacklists that
were called Blacklist to keep people
from really you know being seen by other
people so I guess first that you know
respond to the idea that you know what
they're actually being good corporate
actors here they're going to the best
source or the most official Source
possible trying to get good information
I I think it's certainly acceptable to
get information from the CDC you know
this was their this was their starring
moment
um I think the CDC badly handled its
starring moment you know we could oh
yeah I agree we can talk about all the
things they screwed up but look I would
say there are uh legitimate uh healthy
debates to be had over how effective
mass and what kind of Mass have been at
various levels of the pandemic I think
there are valid questions about where
covet originated and frankly I think
there are valid uh questions about how
necessary vaccines are for young people
and for children and whether potential
risks I don't know that there are very
serious risks but whether potential
there doesn't seem to be very serious
risk for otherwise healthy young people
of the disease itself and and you know
whether at some point even if there's a
low risk of the vaccine there's not
really a benefit for it for that uh that
group actually even the CDC right now is
very angry at uh I believe Pfizer for
not making all of the data available
when they approved it for younger people
so even the CDC itself has some
questions about this because science is
you know it's a it's a process that
involves give and take a change changing
of Mind spouse she's changed himself so
many times during the pandemic sometimes
legitimately other times I would argue
because he was withheld withholding of
of actual facts that he he thought and
he thought we weren't ready to hear them
or he wanted there not to be too many
people getting masks because what if
professionals didn't have them uh anyway
I so I think there are legitimate
discussions to be had on many of these
subjects I think the cdc's default was
too much in the in the wrong direction
and that they would have led Facebook to
not allow those discussions to happen
okay and so how do do we know that
Facebook did not allow the conversations
or or basically was kind of either
um you know blocking or heavily uh
squelching the reach of people who were
espousing things at the F uh that the
CDC didn't what yes even in some of
these emails they explain that but uh
you know they they allude to well this
is already there's a couple that say
this is already violating our policy so
we don't even really need you to tell us
whether you think it's wrong or right
but uh so they're implying that well
then this claim maybe if you depending
on what the CDC says about this claim we
might say that's violating two and we're
gonna we're gonna uh squash that they
did um oh and I know uh from my own
experience how suppressed the um
discussion of the lab leak was for I
think up to a year actually that might
be one case where they actually uh the
CDC might have based on what the CDC
said they might have actually reversed
that policy if I'm following the
timeline correctly
um let's talk about the uh lap link this
is the email uh that pertains to the lab
leak Theory
um and it so this is Facebook moderators
emailing the CDC
saying is the claim covid-19 is man-made
false unproven unsupported by evidence
or true and the CDC responds
inconclusive
um it's technically possible because we
don't know the origin still it being
man-made is theoretically possible but
extremely unlikely and then as you know
Robbie points out this was here's the
terms of service for you know what they
allow and disallow on Facebook and
highlighted there covid-19 is man-made
or manufactured was not allowed for
quite a while on Facebook and then you
know you wrote Robbie that this is this
debacle shows why Banning misinformation
is a terrible idea and I you know it's
like
you can understand it's such an
extraordinary situation uh entering this
this pandemic
um right on the heels of uh an election
where suddenly there's an expectation
that this is the role of social media
companies because that was not always
the expectation uh but you know before
2016 it was like the only thing really
expected of social media companies was
to police like you know terrorist
activity child abuse things like that
and suddenly it brought into well
misinformation got Trump elected and so
they have a responsibility to do this
then a pandemic hits and uh so you can
kind of understand from one perspective
like okay that there's literally lives
on the line here but then there are
situations like the lab League Theory
which still to this day we we don't we
don't know the truth about
you know what what what does what
transpired around the lab leak Theory
make you think about you know the entire
notion of misinformation and and the
government's involvement and that and
social media is involvement in uh kind
of reining it in these are I think the
and these are very different things the
government's legitimate role in sure in
preventing terrorism and organized crime
and violence on social media right I'm a
Libertarian I I think if the government
has some legitimate role to play in
society I think policing violence
terrorism crime is acceptable so in some
sense to me now I still think they
wildly abuse their power on you know
everything the FBI was saying about so
many subjects but you know the FBI says
to Facebook or Twitter Hey this is an
ISIS group you should take this down or
you should give us the information about
it for a law enforcement purpose I don't
think that's inherently legitimate I
think if there's anything that the
government should do it should be doing
that that is so different from
communicating to social medias companies
about what their approach should be to
Therapeutics and vaccines and those
things I get that lives are still on the
line but uh but it it seems much closer
to just policy disagreement and speech
and you know you might not like what
people have to say if they're
anti-vaccine or they don't think the
vaccines are good and you can argue
against that all you want on social
media and may if the platforms
themselves don't like that content it's
their right to take action against it
but I think that is so different from
the government standpoint for the
government to say that our significant
efforts and resources should be
harnessed towards suppressing speech we
disagree with on this subject on social
media I think that's very dangerous and
and very not in line with the proper
function of government I think they were
wrong about a lot of things or at least
some things are questionable and
debatable and and it gets us to a very a
very scary frankly place can I ask is
there a room for the interpretation of
this and I think you can also do this at
Twitter where you know this isn't about
the ownership of uh you know Facebook or
whatever who the hell knows if Mark
Zuckerberg is even still alive or you
know maybe he's been replaced by like a
an animatron or something but I think
he's missing legs now or maybe they
could no he's been selling himself off
to in order to buy you know a full body
in in the metaverse and stuff but what
if this is Facebook's choice you know
and in your writings uh you know and we
always hit this note at reason because
it is important we include the clause in
anything we're writing about these are
private companies and they have you know
wide latitude if not absolute right to
publish what they want to you know to
you know censor what they want Etc
um what if this is the way that Facebook
or you know wanted to go about cleaning
its side up or or regulating its site
um is that a plausible full
understanding and then does that change
the critique in the same way that
Twitter you know it's not clear you know
when you when you hear Jack Dorsey
talking about his personal philosophy
and his life philosophy that wasn't
really being represented at Twitter
because Twitter is run by a lot of
different people uh you know in in the
mid management who are making a lot of
shots so
um you know are these just ways that
these platforms within their rights as
private entities are kind of figuring
out okay what's our take going to be and
what are the parameters of discussion
we're going to allow on our private
platforms absolutely they are within
their rights and in my criticisms of
these companies policies in the past
like you said I always say that look
this is just my criticism as a user I
think it would be better I would prefer
it or it would be better for society or
or whoever if they do something
different but they can do whatever they
want I've always said that
um in reading these emails and in
reading the Twitter files I the question
comes up
what we say it's it's they can do
whatever they want it's their choice did
they feel like it was their choice I
think that's the question
um do they feel like they actually have
a choice when Joe Biden is accusing them
of killing people and Democratic
politicians and Republican politicians
by the way Republicans want to screw up
big Tech and 80 often for doing the
exact opposite thing they're mad for
opposite reasons so they can these
companies can't make Congress happy no
matter what they do but they're they've
been dragged before Congress been made
to answer ridiculous questions from
people who don't understand I mean from
people who are literally geriatric and
you know don't understand you know the
Windows 95 was the last time they had to
grasp on the technology the kids were
using
um they're they think I think they were
rationally very rationally worried about
what government forces were going to do
to them if they didn't uh comply to a to
a great degree so they did and I I don't
think it was terrific for the discourse
that question and of was it a free
choice is really the central question
um and I think a way to dig into that
would be to talk a little bit more about
this court case which we talked a little
bit about on the last stream we had
Robbie on the state of Missouri uh Eric
Schmidt at all versus uh Joe Biden in
the United States government and the the
question that this lawsuit seems to be
trying the legal question seems to be
trying to answer is how far can the
government go with these kind of
pressure tactics before it does become
you know unconstitutional censorship of
speech and in your cover story on this
uh Robbie you go into a concept that is
called uh become known as job owning I
just want to read a little bit of this
excerpt and then uh have you explain
a little bit more about about what job
owning is and you know what what the
legal experts
um how the legal experts Define it and
you know what sort of indicators we we
might be looking for to see if something
Falls within that category or not you're
right you know there's a word for
government officials using the threat of
punishment to extort desired behaviors
from private actors it's job owning the
term arose from the biblical story of
Samson who said of slain a thousand
enemies with the Jawbone of a donkey
according to the economist John Kenneth
Galbraith the words public policy use
began with the World War II era office
of price Administration and civilian
Supply which primarily relied on verbal
condemnation to punish violators so
could you talk about a little bit more
about this concept and whether
any of this behavior that we see in
these emails might fall under that
rubric
right so historically this term was
applied to behavior from political
figures or government agents who you
knew it would take too long to you know
go through the motions of actually
enforcing some kind of Regulation so
they just say hey you guys got to stop
you know raising prices or have it or
out offshoring Outsourcing whatever
we're mad about we just yell at you and
threaten some kind of non-specific
regulation or maybe even some kind of
specific regulation and then they do it
that is job owning this this is the
we're now kind of applying that to
what's going on with speech on social
media which is a little bit different
and I think it's an open question
whether what we've seen from the White
House political figures and government
bureaucrats Rises to that level
obviously the new civil liberties
Alliance in the state of Missouri is
arguing that it does um I interviewed
will Duffield who's a policy analyst of
a free speech expert the Cato Institute
who who thinks that the totality of the
circumstances when you take what Biden
is saying and what these agents are
saying and what the political figures
are saying and what was asked and these
specific invoking of specific
regulations take it all together he
thinks there is a strong case to be made
this is ultimately violating the First
Amendment this is taken together this is
the government restricting a private
entities speech rights
um by by threatening them with uh with
punishment because obviously you
couldn't have a situation where
where um where maybe there's something
that a government actor can't do legally
there's no law but they can you know
extort you or induce you to do something
by threatening to pass some law in the
future or do something else to you right
we would recognize that well then
they're just kind of conveniently
getting around whatever civil rights
protections or civil liberties
protections we have
um there are a couple examples I I bring
up and courts have ruled kind of wildly
different ways on this like um there's
an example of you know a sheriff like a
kind of Christian conservative Sheriff
not wanting there to be a phone sex
hotline in town and you know threatening
the phone company again not threatening
to like blow up the phone company but
you know whatever kind of to bring some
kind of annoying or pestering action
against them so then they get rid of
that that uh that they cut that phone
line you know is that an example of job
owning is is threatening a a bookstore
there was a city council that wanted a
bookstore to stop having what they
thought were a provocative or offensive
books that kind of thing which obviously
you can't yeah the First Amendment says
the government can't couldn't pass a law
saying the bookstore can't have that
book that would be like of such a
straightforward First Amendment
violation so can the council get around
that by saying well we're going to do X
Y and Z to you unless you get rid of
that book that's the question
yeah the the tough thing to determine I
guess is because those are such uh you
know very s you know you're talking
often about small businesses or at least
you know one kind of specific law
enforcement agency and here there's just
so much uh so so many relationships that
are hard to trace all the way back of
who got introduced to whom and there's
you know rotation between when we saw in
the Twitter files that the former FBI
Council was part became Twitter's uh
Council so there's you know the the
revolving door and it's important to
acknowledge that when we're talking
about U.S political figures senators and
members of Congress they have pretty
litigated robust rights to kind of say
whatever they want as much as that is
annoying to us yeah yeah but the
government employees are a different
category and so much of this was coming
from FBI agents bureaucrats at the CDC
you know in some those are our employees
they work for the American taxpayer
um we could certainly come up with I
mean even if there isn't an existing
legal framework that prevents them from
doing that like if the CDC could have
different policies right it's like it's
a government agency that could operate
differently based on uh what we would
constrain it with through regulation or
just or just through who's in charge of
it right there could be policies that
hey it's it's inappropriate for you or
for the FBI to start bossing around
social media companies yeah and I ask
why are we presuming that there is a
conflict of interests or predilections
between the people at Facebook and the
people they were communicating with at
the CDC I mean one of the things of the
Twitter files that came out is that you
know a lot of the people at Twitter were
searching you know they had already made
the conclusion that they wanted to
Shadow ban or squelch the reach of a you
know damp somebody and then they were
just trying to figure out what would be
the pretext because their existing
policies didn't necessarily
um you know uh you know allow for that
um why are we assuming that there is a
broad difference between the people at
Facebook who were sending messages to
the CDC and you know the people at the
CDC who were responding to that because
this is if I may just this is part of a
mostly conservative critique of tech
companies which they are all a bunch of
non-binary you know uh you know marxists
uh postmodern marxists who are you know
trying to destroy America from within
yeah right so I don't agree with that
critique I I disagree with your
characterization slightly although
you're right about the hunter Biden
laptop story that was it was very much
initiative on Twitter's taken by Twitter
itself they suppressed that and then
they try to come up with a justification
for having done so afterward so and that
was the first Twitter files was all
about that the more of them I read
subsequent to that the more it puts that
in context and shows that there actually
was a good amount of skepticism and
pushback not with that specific case but
with so many other cases of law
enforcement coming to them and saying
hey can you get rid of all these
accounts and they'll say they did push
back they pushed back a lot and that
desire to push back collapsed over time
when they were just inundated with
requests and and they were told over and
over again that if you don't do this you
democracy no longer exists if you don't
do more of this that's what the media
was reinforcing to them the mainstream
media is I think another very bad actor
in all of this
um and then they have Democratic
politicians threatening them so they
their their resolve I see their resolve
weakening over time
um Facebook you're right that it in the
covid and the Facebook context I
certainly see you know I I read emails
over a long period of time lots of them
and there was a lot of continuity in
their desire to appease there was not
there wasn't even pushback because it
was very directional from meta asking
the CDC yeah now I'm just reading the
emails they also had constant conference
calls and if you read the tone of the
cdc's responses are so brief and so uh I
I think careful I would I can only
imagine that they were a lot more
instructive in in the conference calls
but obviously I don't know for sure just
a side point about the mainstream Media
or or not mainstream media but Legacy
Media or traditional media I mean like
we're we're you know missing a story too
if we don't think that Mika Brzezinski
for instance or everybody at MSNBC and
everybody at Fox to the extent that they
have these contacts aren't in constant
contact with either people who work in
the government in agencies or you know
top level uh people are actually setting
policy to get their read on stuff like
that and that clearly influences them as
well so in a in a weird way you know
even by focusing on social media it'll
you know we're kind of holding social
media to a very different standard than
we do to traditional media which has a
much bigger footprint and certainly in
terms of Elections you know uh the stuff
that's coming out and I would like to
get back to this when we talk about
remedies you know the one thing you can
say about the 2016 election Facebook
didn't decide the 2016 election it was
you know conventional not even cable
news Broadcast News did that and these
people are you know if if social media
companies are going back and forth with
people in government man I got a feeling
it's like 10 times as bad when you're
talking about ABC CBS NBC I gotta wonder
Nick though isn't there a fundamental
difference there between a pundit at
MSNBC or Fox having a government
official whispering in their ear which
we know for certain was happening with
someone like Sean Hannity texting with
Trump people all the time but you know
Sean Hannity is not running a site
that's shutting down people's accounts
deciding what is allowed to be said uh
you know uh you know what uh Shadow
Banning certain individuals like it it
seems well maybe this is a is a good
moment to you know kind of shift to uh
and we should come back to this lawsuit
that Eric Schmidt has filed and also by
the way I don't know if it's job owning
or whatnot but remember as Attorney
General of Missouri Eric Schmidt joined
49 other State Attorneys General in
trying to and bringing a court case to
break up Google so you know and on the
one hand he's he's like I want to
restrain government from doing this or
that on the other hand as a government
actor he is trying to force a business
to do his bidding so it gets confusing
very quickly but can we
um you know start talking about remedies
then because is you know Robbie I guess
as a starting point is the issue here
not even necessarily what Facebook is
doing but the fact that we don't know
what Facebook is doing we didn't know
what Twitter was doing until your
reporting came out until the Twitter
Files come out is you know is this as
much as anything is it a question of
transparency or where you know platforms
are pretending to be one thing when in
fact they're very different things I
think the issue is what the government
is doing and what the government is
saying to these platforms
um which is the least transparent thing
of all like we I think we've all been
kind of Blown Away right by just by the
volume of communication between
government bureaucrats they spend all
their time like the FBI CDC don't you do
you guys have anything better to do than
bother Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
and whoever else all day to to take down
accounts that you don't like or you
think are wrong or mean to you I mean is
this is it healthy even for our
government to be like accounts with like
30 followers uh you know but they're
obsessed with this they're you know we
just the the world economic forum is
going on in Davos and I watched the
other day the the disinformation segment
where disinformation was framed as the
central problem of our time that all
issues all things bad things facing
Society are Downstream of people saying
crazy or bad things on Facebook and this
was a panel that included Brian stelter
and Seth molden who's Democratic
congressman and a member of the European
Union who like regulates speech for a
living and the person I gotta say who
was like the most hysterically worried
about disinformation was the publisher
of the New York Times who was explicitly
saying that you know we'll never solve
these problems as a society as long as
people can just say whatever they want
on Facebook honestly he was basically
saying that we won't solve any problems
until the Facebook is preferential until
Facebook is preferential treatment to
the New York Times that was basically
the implication of what he was saying
and I think that's such a because as you
pointed out Nick you know the the
explanation for 2016 on on social media
is so I mean it's collapsed there's been
so many studies and surveys now
explaining that you know the Swing Vote
the 60 000 or however many were swing
voters in Michigan and Pennsylvania who
who are working class Bernie supporters
who ended up voting for Trump over
Hillary it's not because Russia told
them on Facebook like these people are
less were less online than the average
human being they they knew Trump from TV
they listened to talk rate radio the
existing media structures were perfectly
sufficient
um so it's really some misplaced
priorities
has been a rewriting of what the rules
are for what you can say on social media
it's people so let's let's talk a little
bit about this though then is Facebook's
problem though uh you know so I mean
you're you're concerned and I I agree
with you completely and I think one of
the great uh benefits and contributions
that your reporting has made and
certainly the Twitter files is by
showing how the inner how much how often
the interactions happen is you know the
volume is important and then the quality
of them when you see the back and forth
and what people are asking and is uh
Zach who uh momentarily disappeared I
we'll see who comes who they come for
next uh but um you know you know just
seeing the level of insanity of like
going after accounts with 30 followers
and and that type of thing but is the
problem problem that Facebook should be
open you know should they be more open
about saying hey you know what we are
not wide open we put parameters on our
speech we remind you of this we make you
you know check off scroll down to the
bottom of the page without reading it
and check off that you agree with our
terms of service but should they be more
open about it should they deny the CDC
any role in kind of uh informing how
they make decisions about what is or is
not allowable discourse should they
allow crowdfunding so that um you know
crowdfunding of information so that when
somebody posts something uh you know a
box pops up and says you know what like
60 of our readers think this is
horseshit 40 you know think that it's
actually you know uh Divine uh you know
divinely inspired words of truth
um you know what what should Facebook be
doing in you know in response to all of
this kind of stuff yeah I would say that
I have not been impressed by expert or
Elite efforts to I police disinformation
or to even frankly to identify it um
they have not seemed to perform
much better at that than anyone else and
in fact the fact checking that Facebook
regularly deploys is these third-party
fact-checking organizations it has a
certain number of them uh I I find them
to be very activist in general I mean
they've flagged things I've written as
fall and then they've changed their mind
when I pointed out that you've actually
like misquoted me I know John Stossel
has had the same problem with them you
know you can think whatever you want
about his lawsuit but I agree with him
on the underlying uh his complaint with
what the fact Checkers had said is it
was totally legitimate but actually what
Twitter is doing is a vast Improvement
on this I think the uh the kind of what
used to be called bird watch and is now
I think Community notes where users get
to offer a fact check and then you can
vote or you can rank or you can weigh in
on how you feel about that note uh you
know Wikipedia has I has this I would
not say entirely figured out but is
doing a lot better than other places on
the internet the uh Community feedback a
kind of Democratic or or crowd-sourced
uh soliciting of opinions has actually
worked out better I would say on the
internet than top-down Solutions or
saying well we're just going to ask a
government expert what the answer is and
then we'll ban everything else how well
has that worked out I would argue not
very well no and you know there are
other examples of kind of collaborative
hive mind maybe I think we've talked
about this in the past you know in the
early odds people were still talking
about the wisdom of crabs it was a
popular book with that title now we know
that crowds are actually mobs so like
you know they're out and experts are
back in or something but there's places
like Reddit you know with subreddits
where one of the things that's
interesting about them you know they
have you can upvote and downvote
comments images whatever information uh
which plays a role but then also all of
the editorial filtering is done very
transparent or very openly and
explicitly
um and that seems to me to be
preferential because you know Robbie
it's interesting you know the world
economic Forum it seems to me that the
world economic forum term is less
powerful it's certainly Less in the
media when it happens than it used to be
20 years ago people wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up about it it seemed like it was
growing now it's kind of a pathetic
place where you know they're you know
they're just pushing their seed oil and
uh fried bug uh you know agenda to fewer
and fewer people to give a [ __ ] and I
think they have less control over
governments the EU isn't even what it
was you know 20 years ago and stuff like
that but um you know the idea that all
of this is disinformation because there
is one truth
um this is a radical
supposition that I think is false and
this is the postmodern libertarian of me
talking is that a lot of this stuff
um there is not one right answer uh
there are many defensible answers and I
will leave it you know to other people
to kind of suss through everything but
it's like you know to if if you really
think that this information is anything
you don't agree with you were born in
the wrong Century because more people
have more access to more information and
also to you know hold and to kind of
share and distribute their worldview
however [ __ ] stupid you might find it
and I think as Libertarians we really
should responsibly be upholding that you
know this is for me I've always you know
for over 20 years I've likened all of
this to what happened in England in the
17th century when the Church of England
was essentially disestablished as the
one religion the one way you could
practice Christianity and hence
everything hence religion in England it
you know it it led to a flowering of all
kinds of different religious sects and
once they were granted legitimacy as
long as they weren't violent uh you know
then you just had more and more
different groups of people believing
different things professing different
things trying to evangelize for that
point of view and out of that comes
freedom of conscience freedom of speech
all of the things that I think 21st
century Libertarians and the vast
majority of Americans hold near and dear
which is that like you you get to live
your life the way you want it to to the
greatest degree possible you get to run
your business the way you want to Etc uh
these are good values and so for me
there's an epistemological issue with
the way the world economic forum and a
lot of experts uh whether they're on the
right or the left or even Libertarians
want to pronounce something as truth
with a capital T and force you you know
to eat it like it's uh Clash webs uh
Clash swabs uh future diet for the
planet but this is like this seems to be
the current policy of the federal
government it's like they uh and it's
just it just seems to get amped up every
year I there I want to play this clip
from Vivek uh Murthy that's I think
illustrates this and the Surgeon General
yeah those of you who are woefully and
wonderfully uh not into this stuff yes
and I'd like to get your your actually
both your reactions to it on this point
of the way that uh misinformation
um kind of is this like creeping concept
that gets absorbed in all sorts of weird
ways but let's listen to Mercy for a
second
I issued a surgeon general's advisory
on the dangers of Health misinformation
Surgeon General advisories are reserved
for Urgent Public Health threats and
while those threats have often been
related to what we eat drink and smoke
today we live in a world where
misinformation poses an imminent and
Insidious threat to our nation's health
so I mean he's defining misinformation
quite literally as a public health
threat I mean his job is is public
health
um I guess my question is for you nick
uh following up on what you just said
you know what is the way to is this just
an inevitable creep uh you know kind of
cultural acceptance of
yeah misinformation is something that
has to be policed like from the top down
and is there any way to you know keep
that at Bay yeah well you know uh last
week we uh did a live stream with
Michael Heiss of the mises caucus and
despite many disagreements you know one
thing that he talked about was you know
that culture
um you know culture precedes politics
and whatnot and I think the short answer
the way that we push back against this
is ultimately a cultural one where we
look at people like the Vivek Murthy we
look at people like Joe Biden we look at
people like Donald Trump who tried very
hard to you know Jawbone and to scare
various people into shutting up and
doing his bidding in a particular way
it's like that that does not work that
is so fundamentally Un-American uh that
there may be times when you really do
have to regiment certain types of speech
if there is some kind of massive uh in
invasion of the United States if there
is some kind of smallpox level uh you
know black plague level uh threat for a
short limited uh clearly you know term
limited time period or something where
we're suspending our normal rules maybe
but we have to push back against this
kind of stuff and the one thing and I
think you know Robbie's reporting over
the years and particularly the
flip-flops on all kinds of covid truths
that were later revealed to be like ah
that was a bad conjecture or that was
something totally wrong and we knew all
along is like experts have been doing a
very good uh you know job certainly
through the 20th century and into the
21st century of showing how bad they are
at understanding the thing the very
thing they're trying to control but this
is where I think a really robust culture
of free speech and open expression needs
you know we need to be doing everything
we can to build that up because in the
end the laws you know the laws can be
there or not but it's really the culture
and the way people approach knowledge
pluralism and uh you know and and the
right to live and think the way that you
want is what's going to make the biggest
difference
let me pull up a couple uh questions
from the audience here that uh pertain
to what we were just saying first just a
uh a compliment and the five dollar
donation from AJ Dizzle thank you AJ
um and uh Matthew Harvey says uh Nick
for one is constantly talking about how
libertarian
libertarianism is about more than just
government and we should advocate for a
culture of free speech I think that's
what you were just doing there
um and this is a question uh that I
wonder if Robbie might address uh since
we're talking about how we got here how
this kind of acceptance of uh this
top-down management of the flow of
speech became so widespread Dan Glenn
asks was this being done in the last
Administration or since 2020
right so most of the emails that I saw
in this release which I've termed the
Facebook files was from the Biden
Administration they were from 2021 but
we know that uh that the FBI was talking
to Twitter and warning them about you
know so-called Russian disinformation
election stuff that was going on under
Trump trump you know for all his
complaints about the Deep state did
absolutely nothing nothing less than
nothing he he complained about it in a
useless way
um did not fire anyone you know unless
they really crossed him personally
that's what's so
um so sickly about the Republican
criticism of these institutions is that
it's only they only care if people are
being spied on or their rights are being
violated if it's like literally Donald
Trump and then they you know lose their
mind over it and we're saying like the
Patriot Act should have never been
signed stop reauthorizing it if you're
so mad stop stop and except for you know
like a few Brave Republicans who have
been consistent on this stuff since the
very beginning since before Trump your
masses your Pauls Etc everyone else just
just doesn't do anything to to fix it
because and then ultimately really well
I absolutely agree with with Nick about
fostering a culture of Liberty and a
free speech at the end of the day
somebody's got somebody's got to get
elected and get rid of a couple like the
TSA no amount of cultural change can get
rid of the TSA should be gotten rid of
tomorrow right it should just be shut
down and someone government just has to
like do that they just have to follow
through on what is obvious I I think the
communications policies at the FBI and
the CDC for one should be Revisited I
think so what do you think agents
routinely look at Twitter for like
accounts making fun of them and ask
Twitter to take those down they do okay
who did that they should not have that
job dude what do you think about the
legislation uh I think Zach flashed it a
while ago but uh this bill uh that would
effectively speak from government
interference act which Robbie references
in his cover story right
um and is that is that a what is that
Robbie and is that a plausible remedy
yeah so that would do along the lines of
what I'm saying it would treat uh
government employees trying to Jawbone
private com
oh we lost Robbie for a second there
um yeah I mean I was just says it was
getting good
I I was looking at the text of this a
little bit earlier and um essentially it
is it prevents it it prohibits
government actors whether that is
elected officials or people involved
with agencies from us demanding uh
censorship on social media platforms so
asking just the kind of behavior that
was shown in the uh uh Facebook emails
uh the CDC would not be allowed to be
involved in saying this kind of content
is not a lot well actually that's a
question I have for Robbie when he comes
back is how much of that would be
disallowed because they aren't in many
cases specifically asking for specific
accounts to be taken down in this case
they're kind of in this ongoing
consultation between them and Facebook
the Twitter files it's a little more
clear because there's specific accounts
where the FBI is flagging them and
saying look this violates your terms of
service you better uh take a closer look
at that and that is what this bill is
explicitly designed to stop right yeah
um so how do you how do you feel about
that I mean it's uh I know we've had an
ongoing conversation about this you're
amenable to that in principle do you
think
um you know which is not a bad you know
I I think that's totally defensible
um but you know do you think does this
bill as written do you think it gets
that job done I mean my immediate
reaction to it is well it sounds pretty
good to me
um I me you know I haven't studied it in
detail but uh the concept of doing
something to try to rein this in I think
would would be a positive step
um
those those issues like we were talking
about like well what about just kind of
even vager Communications or these
semi-formal relationships as fact
Checkers uh between the social media
companies and and government agencies I
don't know that that would be covered or
that by that bill or that that even
could be covered legislatively so right
at some point I think you know we we
should support things that that improve
the situation even if they don't solve
any everything but uh you know the the
real solution and this is the the drama
I'm always banging is uh technological
like it we've got Facebook we've got
Twitter but the important thing is that
there's always channels that are
relatively unrestrained that those
always exist and you know more people
over the years have been migrating to
services like signal or telegram where
right a little bit more uh decentralized
I'm now on You Know Jack uh Noster which
is this new decentralized uh
um Communications protocol where your
your tweets or you know your posts are
kind of just relayed around a hundred
different places so there's no single
point of failure like those are the
kinds of systems that ultimately
Safeguard against a you know
totalitarian Crackdown on speed yeah
yeah I mean I agree with that but they
also I mean if the if the uh means of
communication is decentralized says the
audience right so
um oh yeah I you know I I mean I I agree
with you completely and you know Jack
Dorsey again I think is the most
interesting uh you know billionaire or
or let's put it in less loaded terms of
tech founder the most Visionary in terms
of wanting an internet of internets you
know uh you know a Twitter of Twitter is
that so there's no way to shut it all
down but you know what we're talking
about here is when an audience gets big
enough that's when the government is
going to try and do something and I'm I
agree you know broadly speaking There
are rules in place against uh in all
sorts of contexts uh you know where if
you work in a congressman's office or
something you can't do electioneering
you can't you know out of your main
account you're not allowed to do that uh
you know of people who work at state
universities know that they're not
allowed to use State uh you know list
serves that are within the university
setting for political campaigning and
things like that there are rules against
that they kind of work people still do
it I am going to come back to this
question of you know how do we um you
know how do we create a culture that
does not allow this so that there is a
you know the breaks that are put on this
are not legalistic but rather you know
kind of uh etiquette based almost where
it's like no that is considered poor
form if you're in government I mean I
guess I want something more than that
but it's also you know the more and more
that you you know the more regulations
you put on speech in any given context
it seems to me then you create you know
more lawsuits you create more uh
jesuitical kind of analysis of
everything and then we spend all of our
time you know kind of doing compliance
work rather than just getting on with
whatever conversation we're trying to
have that's why that's why it's it's
crucial I think for us Libertarians to
be insistent that any such regulations
be firmly on the government side of the
equation
um so that's what was you know
immediately appealing about that
particular act as it seemed to uh be on
it should be restraining government
officials and not necessarily imposing
anything on the private companies
because they need to be free to
experiment with this stuff uh and um
it's it's a real concern that a lot of
the momentum and kind of political
energy is towards the opposite uh where
okay we're going to you know the uh Joe
Biden and uh the Democrats want to use
section 238 to make uh the the social
media companies Bend the need to us so
the conservatives need to get in and use
section 238 to make them moderate things
to our liking that seems to be kind of
the back and forth that's going on right
now and that's uh extremely destructive
and uh let's yeah let's uh hopefully
Robbie is going to join us we got word
that is his computer died but and let's
turn to two Supreme Court cases that are
challenging section 230 in a second but
I want to read a couple of comments uh
in our readers because we're trying to
be interactive here sparkwitch uh writes
let's be real conspiracy theory just
means we'll have proof soon at this
point yeah maybe uh what are the
penalties for abuse of power by
government actors ask 2v news that's a
good question
uh yeah well this new this new bill
might be something that could actually
create some of that leverage and again I
don't know that this if this specific uh
legislation is right or not but you know
something that's targeting government
actors I think is certainly what should
interest us yeah Matthew butts uh comes
up with Canard but reason I thought
Facebook was a private company that can
do what they want
LMAO uh you know I think we've covered
this this is you know I I don't
understand when people get on this hobby
horse because it's like okay so you want
it to be a government regulated utility
then or a common carrier or something
like that and it's like come on you know
uh I don't think that's good you know
and I and and these two things are not
uh you know exactly at odds what we're
dealing with is a shift in understanding
how power operates which is that you
know it is no longer the sledgehammer it
is you know it's the sweet talker you
know the uh the Iron Fist and a velvet
Club half the time or it's a common uh
you know it's it's a common kind of
growth of interest uh we're assuming
that Facebook's interests and the
government's interests are wildly at
odds and I I think we would need to
prove that in anything yeah and I'll
also just say that we do need to accept
on some level that a private company is
uh and the people who run it are going
to do things and make decisions that we
don't like and uh that's kind of like
the the price of freedom and you can't
uh legislate that that that's why I take
uh exception to the idea that you're
going to use section 2 30 or something
like that to kind of force
your interpretation of like a free
speech platform on on everyone that
that's not the way to do it the way to
do it is by you know gravitating towards
the platform that you know suits suits
your needs the best and supporting that
you know we talked about Shifting the
culture one person who's doing that
right now is Elon Musk with his Twitter
takeover which I've been generally
supportive of not people I think Elon
Musk is you know doing everything right
but at least he has kind of shaken
things up and uh he's he's uh shaking
those assumptions that we were talking
about earlier that everything has to be
managed so strictly and that
misinformation is this problem that can
only be solved by automated moderation
at scale he's kind of questioning some
of some of those assumptions we don't
know how it's all going to shake out but
we want to that's where we want to
experiment implementation to play out I
think and uh yeah again with Twitter I
mean everybody was bitching and moaning
about it before he took over they're
bitching and Mining about it now I have
to say and I'm a very heavy user of
Twitter I've spent a lot of time there
I've built up a lot of presence there I
have a hundred and fifteen thousand
followers or something insane I do not
notice any difference seriously I mean
like maybe on the margins because a
couple of people are back who had been
banned but you know it's like I either
read them or I don't I mean but
functionally it's exactly pretty much
the uh the same as it was before so uh
you know and I'm there for the lulls
mostly looks like we got Robbie back can
you hear me I can yes we can great yeah
uh and you know we can't even see where
they roughed you up so that's good
here I think uh yeah the Old Timer still
got it but uh valtry was kicking your
shin so hard you almost felt it
um let's we have moved into a point now
where we're going to talk about the two
Supreme Court cases that are under uh
uh under uh you know uh
consideration thank you this term
Twitter Inc versus tomna and uh uh
Gonzalez versus Google each of these
cases this is somewhat related to what
we're talking about here because they
threaten uh you know section 230 which
is the law dating back to the mid 90s
that allows interactive computer
services such as isps such as websites
such as platforms you know whether it's
Yelp or Facebook or YouTube to uh
moderate some content without having to
do all the content uh you know they
don't they can pick and choose what they
choose to moderate or and allow or
disallow uh and it also indemnifies them
from most third-party content so you
know if a user writes a defamatory
review of a restaurant on Yelp or on
Google Maps or something those those
companies are not on the hook for it
there are things that are still illegal
and that the platform can be held
responsible for but section 230 is
considered the internet's First
Amendment it's a 27 words that made the
internet the internet it effectively
undergirds all of what we call social
media or Web 2.0 for sure
um Robbie what do you think about these
cases
um they both deal with things where uh
claiming that the different platforms
Twitter and Google did not
did not curate their content enough so
that terrorist acts happened because
people were exposed to terroristic
thinking and videos and content on these
platforms
um you know what's your sense of these
particular cases and the fate of section
230 in the Contemporary judicial and
political climate sure everyone who
loves free speech and wants the
platforms to be more open environments
for free speech should really be hoping
for Section 230 to survive the way it is
uh should be rooting you know for these
for these lawsuits Not to cause us to
destroy the beautiful thing that we have
warts and all because imagine I mean
we're complaining about moderation
decisions that were made I would argue
made a lot at the behest of government
but this is what they did under the
current regime imagine if they were had
more liability for what is considered
bad speech on the platforms imagine how
much more censorship how much more
restriction how much more silencing of
important conversations would occur
under a regime where Facebook and
Twitter and Google uh were worried about
liability for what anyone says on the
platform like this it's so obvious that
this would not benefit
contrarians conservatives Libertarians I
mean it's so uh characteristic of
horribly misguided Republican approach
to handling these issues that it almost
baffles the mind I mean I I try to say
to Republicans you know Elizabeth Warren
supports this plan you know she wants to
get rid of section 230 probably not
because that will lead to a
proliferation of conservative speech
right it's just so it's not it's not
thought through at all like the
immediate ramification of making the
platforms more liable for speech that
appears on them would be a vast vast
silencing that's just that's that's
obvious
um if you just care about I guess like
making life more difficult for Facebook
and Twitter and you don't really care
about Free Speech maybe you would
support this I I the only argument
against section 230 that I I have some
understanding of or sympathy for they'll
say look this is a tremendous protection
for these companies I I think it's one
that makes sense that they're not
responsible for you know if you libel
someone on a Facebook comment Facebook's
not responsible that makes sense it is
true that that is not a protection that
it doesn't work that way for traditional
public non-web environment Publishers
write the the book publisher is more
responsible for the books that you it's
a little bit different Honestly though I
would say we should then
um we should make the policies that
applied to traditional non-web
Publishers more like section 230 would
probably be my answer to that rather
than make everyone more scared of libel
like that doesn't create a good free
speech environment and in fact other
countries even peer countries in the
Western World Australia for one that
have uh that are more in favor of the
default more to privacy versus Free
Speech there you can't say anything
critical of a powerful person you'll be
sued out of existence it's a major
problem for newspapers so let's let's
not go in that direction it just it
doesn't make any sense to me what about
you Zach uh do you uh fear the outcomes
of these cases and you know there's that
quote from a previous uh uh ruling or
writing by uh Clarence Thomas where he
has you know he has signaled very
clearly he thinks 230 is a bad idea and
that there needs to be more regulation
of online mind speech
you know our do you think section 230
can go uh into that good night or should
go should it be reformed
um you know are you worried about the
outcomes in these cases I I am worried
about the outcomes and I I share uh both
Robbie's concern and kind of
bewilderment that this is like the
strategy because it's kind of premised
on the idea of well we'll also somehow
control the levers of power indefinitely
and like use it the way that it should
be used and I think Libertarians are
very attuned to the sense that that does
not uh ever work out
um and the but the biggest concern I
have about section 230 is the way it's
continually leveraged to uh possibly
Jawbone these companies into compliance
and it to that end I would support uh I
maybe there's there could be efforts to
fortify like I think we should be going
in the opposite direction a fist of
etiquette a regular commenter here kind
of summarizes it nicely nice private
company you have there be a shame if
someone over regulated it that is
exactly the tone that these past few
years have conveyed to me
um and so if anything I would like to
see uh it fortified and protected um and
then again uh we have to have the
technological solutions as well that are
kind of resilient against whatever
however this plays out because if if you
know if if if this effort succeeds
um there will be networks that survive
it uh I'm optimistic about that yeah I
agree with that and you know with these
two court cases in particular
um one of the things that bothers me
beyond the section 230 question is that
both of them are premised uh you know
they they were um you know launched by
families who had children adult children
who were killed or teenage and adult
children who were killed in terrorist
attacks uh not in the United States by
the way but they're saying you know
Google Twitter Facebook didn't police
and regulate terroristic content on
their website it's not even clear that
they can show the particular terrorists
who killed their family you know watched
you know they started out watching a uh
Rick and Morty video on YouTube and then
suddenly ended up you know in a nicest
training camp you know that's how I was
free videos yeah no but but that
mentality which also underwrites this
whole concept of stochastic terrorism
and whatnot is a refraction of an insane
stupid and thoroughly refuted argument
in the 1990s that was leveled again
against at that time the internet but
also cable TV and whatnot which was that
somehow exposure to Fantasy violence and
fantasy sexual imagery and whatnot had
immediate and obvious and unidirectional
Real World experience you watch violence
on TV you go out and you become violent
that is not true in the social
scientific literature Robbie I know in
Tech Panic uh your your recent book you
talked about other studies and things
like that like this whole idea first off
that somehow YouTube is funneling people
into you know their you know their
secret vertical of Isis training videos
and decapitation you know uh uh uh
how-to videos and things is just wrong
but that mentality that you are what you
watch and you become programmed by the
media that you take in is so flawed and
is so anti-freedom uh that is a really
really big thing this is one of those
arguments I thought that had been uh you
know kind of like had a stake driven
through its heart like you know Dracula
um but it's back
um and that's apart from section 230 but
you see this start to come up when
people who want to be in charge of
things feel like they're losing control
they start trotting out these arguments
this happened in the 90s as the internet
and as cable TV proliferated people in
charge people like Janet Reno Bill
Clinton's attorney general Bill Clinton
Hillary Clinton uh did this you know
they wanted to control the discourse and
they knew they couldn't so then they
started invoking these phantasms of you
know of of media that like essentially
programs us as robots to do whatever the
whatever bad person they think is in
charge to do uh we got to be fighting
that as well as section you know
challenges to section 230 because it's
not simply the internet we have is the
best internet we can have and it's not
you know but it's definitely true if you
take Section 230 away and don't replace
it with a better or more robust defense
of wide open speech we're going to be
living in a much crappier world than we
live in now that's for sure social media
companies are under tremendous attack
from right left and Center uh you know
we keep it's exactly as you describe
Dracula has returned from the dead or
maybe he's already dead he gets out of
his coffin again I don't know uh it's
all uh repeating repetitions of that
argument actually you turned me on to
this one Nick the the hidden uh the
hidden persuaders the the Vance Packard
thing where in the 1960s this
psychologist who wrote about how
advertising you know there's subliminal
messages and advertising and we're all
going to be you know zombies no longer
in control of our actions because of
that development and and the social
dilemma which is I think the most like
propagandistic uh film I have ever seen
in my life uh makes the same argument
for what social media is doing now where
there's so much worry about the harms to
kids which and look it is not that there
is no downsides of social media it is
certainly not the case that no one
anywhere has made their lives worse or
has made their parents has many people
have have made their paranoia worse so
their anxiety worse or some just like
gambling is a big problem for addicts
most people can go to the casino and
have a good time and it's fine some
people uh end up abusing whatever it is
and but we don't make policy for
everyone or at least we shouldn't I
think in a very strictly libertarian
sense you don't ban things for the
entire population because some people
have had a struggle with it and this is
so the case with social media even with
young people most young people are using
it to communicate with their friends to
express themselves creatively to network
and find communities that were not
available to them they are they're
finding like-minded communities around
their interests I have used social media
in this way I'm connected to so many
people I would have never known all
across the world who like the same video
games I do or cartoon shows or whatever
or political ideologies you know they it
conservatives and and also many
progressives act like we'd all be better
we'd never had these smartphones and you
could just sit in your village and you
would only know like your neighbors and
you would you know instinctively hate
and fear anyone who looks different like
from you or doesn't think the way you do
like that's how most human beings lived
for all of society and uh I don't think
it's an improvement and I actually don't
think like 98 of the people who say this
is so great would actually enjoy living
this way and try to try to take their
smartphones away try to take Amazon away
from them see see if they would actually
like it a lot better I'm guessing no the
other thing about that is that even if
there were some improvements there's
it's it's kind of a fantasy like there's
no going back and you know there's
always with any technological tool any
new to medium it's going to create new
effects and new phenomena that we have
to adapt to and that is I think what is
is happening right now is there's been
this shift in how we all consume
information and it's created conditions
that allow new things to happen that
that were not possible before Donald
Trump might be one of those things but
there's lots of uh you know good uh
social phenomena that have emerged out
of this Robbie mentioning different
communities that have emerged solely
that would not exist
except for the online you know ecosystem
and we just have to have a more mature
recognition that all tools are
double-edged and sometimes you have to
use the tool that is causing some
problem somewhere to also solve that
same problem and it requires some you
know experimentation and unfortunately
failure in certain Realms to get there
one of the comments down here kind of uh
struck me Anthony Priestess said YouTube
is prompting me to get the latest
information from the CDC about covid-19
uh green face smiling so that's like we
get this all the time on our YouTube
videos here if we touch a controversial
topic there will be like an
auto-generated Wikipedia uh entry
beneath it saying Get the facts about
this topic and as a someone who puts
stuff up on YouTube I have zero problem
with that honestly like I'm as long as
it's evenly applied uh that and that
those are the kinds of technological
solutions I'm talking about where you're
using this ability to keep layering
information on top of information uh you
know we that we touched on you know bird
watch or Community notes earlier
um that that's the beauty of the digital
sphere is you can meet bad information
with more information and I I just hope
we can get back to that idea like as a
culture that that is a good idea and and
that is the way to combat bad ideas I
think that uh you know as we're going to
wrap up in a second but you know for me
this always comes back to the point
about media literacy
um you know that in the end we're
individuals and whether we are up to the
challenge we ultimately are left holding
the bag for our own lives and our own
thoughts and our own actions and that
all the experts in the world and you
know we can access them more now you
know for two hundred dollars a year you
can buy like two Master Class passes or
whatever so you can get you know the
greatest Minds in TV telling you how to
write sitcoms all of this kind of [ __ ]
it's like it comes down to you know you
you have to be responsible for educating
yourself and checking your bias and kind
of learning more and better and all of
that kind of stuff Robbie just as a
final note and we'll we'll give you uh
the final word to sum up a little bit I
mean I think what your work did you know
the cover story of the next issue of
Reason magazine if you're listening go
to reason.com subscribe uh you know it's
like 15 20 bucks a year uh you get uh
access to our archives all of this kind
of stuff it's for 11 issues it's
wonderful
um but you know both in the cover story
that's coming up as well as in the piece
that you just put up today I mean you
help us understand how media operates
now and how not just media but
information how power operates it is not
you know the it's not the bludgeon it's
not the sledgehammer it's a lot kind of
softer and kind of gooier and
omnidirectional than that including the
ways that private actors can influence
government
um but you know in the end what's the
final I guess to uh to wrap up what's
the final takeaway you want readers of
the of your coverage of the Facebook
files to really kind of make sure that
they you know take hard about and really
think about going forward sure I I think
if you share my concern and maybe you
don't but I hope you do that the
combination of constant messaging from
government Health bureaucrats and then
and also actually FBI agents on separate
subjects but for government actors to
private social media companies at the
same time that political figures were
threatening these companies very
explicitly the combined impact of that
which resulted in uh vast restriction in
how you could discuss the covid-19
pandemic
um
is concerning and potentially at least
maybe more than potentially violates the
First Amendment at least violates the
spirit of the First Amendment
um I I don't think it's appropriate to
have closed off the debate about mass
and even about vaccines the way that
they did it's much bigger and broader
than we could have ever imagined and if
we don't like it and we want to do
something about it we have to change the
government's actual practices because
punishing the social media companies
will end up getting us in a much worse
place I think that's so clear and
something Republicans especially need to
listen to as they you know take over
parts of the government and plot how
we're going to respond
um we need to train our you know train
your fire put your fire on big
government big Tech has been a problem
but mostly in its uh subordinate
Behavior to big government and we we
don't want to get rid of social media
companies entirely we don't want to
break them all up we don't want to
destroy them because at the end of the
day we're living through the greatest
time for Distributing
libertarian and provocative and
alternative ideas that have ever existed
we need these platforms they have been
good for our messages in a way the
traditional Media or the elite media the
mainstream media that would never let
you listen to these messages has not in
fact Not only would they never have let
you listen to these messages they are
right now working in tandem with the
forces I just described they're the ones
who most want to suppress uh social
media or to encourage social media to uh
to take away your microphone Robbie uh
talk a little bit about the hill uh and
Rising you co-host a show there every
day uh what is that what's the best way
for people to uh check that out
absolutely it's a Daily Show a morning
show that airs on YouTube for The Hills
YouTube channel it's called Rising I
co-host it usually with Brianna Joy gray
who's someone of the left so it's a
little bit of uh people from alternative
perspectives having debates on uh on the
issues of the day and on the news it's a
lot of fun I love doing it I bring on a
lot of reason people actually today we
had on both uh both Liz's of Reason uh
this week we did we had on Liz Wolfe
earlier and we had on Elizabeth Nolan
Brown today so I'm I'm using it to uh
get uh to call attention to the great
work that my colleagues at reason are
doing as well thank you uh Zach Have You
Been on Rising I haven't had that one
yeah yes it was a wonderful uh
invitation thank you Robbie and also
thank you to uh Norm van duker for the
ten dollar uh donation on the way out uh
you cannot Outsource your responsibility
for what happens in your life to a
government agency says Norm I think
that's what we're all saying here so
thank you uh and I'll also just point
out very quickly uh uh best buyers are
uh social media uh Maven uh rights can
you please address all the people
defending this people say they're
private companies but colluding with
government to silence dissent isn't
private company Behavior it's communist
Behavior I actually think technically
that would be fascist Behavior because
the government does not own the means of
production but I think we've covered
that
um transparency is good transparency is
out
um I think there remain uh serious
questions about whether or not Facebook
Twitter Etc are doing what they you know
they agree with the government and
they're happy to carry water or not
we've discussed that but uh knowing
what's going on and that's certainly the
big takeaway from uh Robbie's work uh
today and in the next solution of Reason
Zach uh our next live stream will be
next Thursday it's school choice week
we're going to have Robert pondicio on
he's one of the most interesting
educational analysts who is just a
phenomenal out of the box thinker so
we're going to have him next week uh
Zach what else are you working on you
have been a uh you know just a fire hose
a fantastic documentary work at reason
uh reason Reasons video platform or
channel uh at YouTube reason TV uh what
have you done recently and what do you
got in the pipeline
uh recently I I put out a essay kind of
a video essay a video op-ed kind of
summarizing uh the Twitter files and
what I think that Libertarians uh might
take away from that so uh if you're
interested in this conversation that
might be interesting to you uh in the
future I'm uh near future I'm headed to
Texas to work on a documentary about
homelessness and solutions to
homelessness it's an issue I've covered
many times uh over the years uh when I
lived in California and now I'm going to
Texas to look at some different
approaches yeah so go to uh youtube.com
reason TV for our videos we've got live
we've got verticals for live stream
we've got shorts we've got videos Etc
it's a great place to go Robbie Suave of
Reason author most recently of tech
Bennett co-host of the of rising every
day on the Hills YouTube channel thank
you for joining reason my pleasure thank
you guys so much and Zach Weissmuller
thank you again for uh co-hosting this
live stream and putting together all of
our clips and again I really want to
recommend people go check out his work
you can also get all of our work at
reason.com Google around look around for
that but um it's great stuff thank you
Zach thank you Nick